[Applause]
it is registration day everybody is
checking in for the big event coming up
this weekend I am so excited
[Applause]
I don't think any of them I don't think
WDC has an awesome scholarship program
where 350 winners are chosen from
applications all around the world to
attend the conference over 75% of them
are first-time attendees which speaks to
the huge adoption of Swift and the
everyone can code curriculum it's
expanding coding to so many more people
and if you want to apply to be a
potential future WDC scholarship winner
you just have to be a student or a
member of a stem organization I'll put a
link in the description so you guys can
check it out for more info this was so
fun to witness these young developers
getting a chance to talk to Tim and show
them the things that they've been
working on for the past year and in a
few seconds I'm gonna get a chance to
chat with a few of these developers and
see what it was like to meet him but but
first I got to meet Tim - he just told
me the stories that you're like 15 yeah
you first came across from my videos
last year you saw me at W DC I was like
hope I see her this year would be crazy
if I did I'll get a picture and I did
and they just happen just met briefly
did you get a chance to see Tim thank
you I get to talk to her how was it it
was really great because the last one
the last moments she said all guys are
leaving you and then I said do you want
to see my playground video yeah my
submission and he said yes and he is
amazing and what is the app that you
created
yeah it's called clever if I kiss you -
yeah that's a lie yeah but in Russia
[Music]
so my name is Josie Ramaswamy and I
created a knot safety and this is your
third Dom BWC you said yeah what's it
like coming here to spend your third
time it's really fun I love the
conference I mean I just thought meeting
a different individuals to coach and
around the world so what is your app
that you've been created called safety
pin so it essentially it just helps
people who are victims of sexual assault
seek legal justice so like during times
of emergency it will help them record
whatever is going on if they just shake
the phone it's not a light topic yeah so
I think that is something that is very
serious and with technology if you do
you'll be able to solve these issues
previously were never even created we
actually have a website think steam the
number for girls that were so inspired
right now like this is amazing so if
there's any other girls out there join
us now you had any advice to give to
women or girls who are looking to get
into coding here do it I mean it might
seem hard at first especially since it
might be intimidating just taking that
one leap of confidence and being that
one girl you may just feel more
empowered itself and then you might
other girls and other girls to feel
confident like this is so
congratulations thank you so great
there's so many incredible scholarship
winners that I've got to meet so many
amazing ones and there's also an ice
cream truck so hi could I get a vanilla
look how would you like Tyler chocolate
and what kind would you like
good thank you it's a wildly vaper ice
cream would you like to introduce
yourself to my youtube friends sure hi
I'm Lilly Chad I'm a sophomore for New
Jersey so I yeah WWE C as in a woman in
tech activist and also an
environmentalist so how did your get
into coding is just something that you
always wanted to do or I've always been
very interested in stem I always did
like math competitions as you gonna do
the past two years I just started
putting it off starts with like Java and
I branded talking to things like is she
learning and data
[Music]
I'm Convy I'm a junior traditional high
school and I'm working on an app called
Asia I saw you talking to Tim earlier
with that life
it was crazy like I was talking to the
other and I was like what's going on I
turn around and it's coming here and
getting like show your work it's really
crazy because I actually live like right
across from the Avenue campus like
seeing him is kind of like seeing like
my whole life childhood like it's like
whoa like I see you every day yeah
it's crazy like on TV and now I'm seeing
in person you showed him your work today
that's incredible I was freaking out for
you so what is the app that you created
yeah so it's an app called a aegis and
means Athena's shield I know that one of
the biggest problems on University
campuses is safety for women and men
sexual assault is a really big deal and
I really wanted to do something to like
help aid that so I created this app
that's basically a buddy system for men
women to friend each other and like
connect to each other so they could get
to destination safely I started creating
it at a hackathon women agree
you guys people in general because I
have like this passion is you see a
problem and you're like I'm not just
gonna stand by passively I'm going to
fix that yeah that's I think that's the
best part of being like a programmer
because like if you don't have these
skills you always think like there's
something I should do they're like you
don't know how to really handle it but
when you have like this kind of power
there's so many things that you could do
like you could really create apps like
this I mean you really can't do anything
we're just crazy and I think that's a
joy out programming class for the future
it's just so cool thank you so much for
chatting with us thank you thank you so
you worked every see first yeah you
inspired her so how did that all happen
like every year I watched the keynote
yeah I saw him and now it's a girl I'm
going also and then I saw that I could
apply also now he's old enough he got it
last year and it was like I was jealous
of him and I was like next year I'm
going to get in and I'm gonna go do it
with you I started learning out of code
after summer and he told me to use you
to me online horses
help me with that and I did after school
that's really cool so now you guys are
both here you guys working on apps
together we're gonna start working yeah
that's really cool that's so much fun I
work a lot with my sister too so it's
always so Winans I feel like you guys
kind of get each other
you don't say anything you're like you
know congrats on your first WDC Congrats
on your second one this is so awesome
I'm so excited to see what you guys
create what are you most looking forward
to being here seeing more girl coders
yeah I had to look through a lot of
years to talk to the girls there's only
like two or three years really what
would you say to other girls that might
be interested in becoming coders or you
know getting into program what would be
your advice to them just do it try and
camper that's true what would your
advice be to girls to do it go online
look for resources go yeah that's
awesome I feel like that's my best
advice you heard like oh how do I become
a youtuber like you just do it the first
step is the hardest just go do something
make something oh my gosh it's so great
to meet you guys you too
[Music]
hi I'm Matt I'm a part-time WWDC
scholarship winner I work on PI tracking
technology for iOS devices did you know
that you have to talk to Tim Cook today
yeah it was great I already knew that
cuz I was there I was freaking out I was
so excited for you like that was such an
incredible experience what was that like
getting to show Tim what you I've made
an app that once you draw just by moving
your head so this is again for
accessibility's to helping people who
can't necessarily touch the screen
create heart so I actually had Tim Cook
play around with it and he creates wall
painting by
I just have the most incredible time
getting to meet so many amazing
scholarship learners getting a chance to
talk to them was honestly so surreal
because I actually started out wanting
to be a developer I wanted to be a
computer programmer I started
programming when I was maybe like 12 or
13 I made my own websites and so I
taught myself HTML and then shortly
after that I went and started learning
Java and CSS and then in college I
learned ActionScript and I was doing
flash development and all that kinda
stuff but the whole point of this is is
when I started doing this stuff I was so
young and to see people now having this
access to technology and be able to come
here to babble and show people what
they're working on is just such a
surreal thing just for me to experience
it through their eyes so being able to
come here and meet them and talk to them
and see the amazing things that they're
working on was so awesome
I'm so looking forward to WDC this week
and I can't wait to see what they
announce but it is really amazing what
Apple is doing so they have 350
scholarship winners to come here so you
guys can actually be a scholarship
winner so I am so excited that I got to
experience this I also have to meet Tim
Cook which was a really surreal
experience I wasn't expecting that at
all act like it was such a shock that my
first words to Tim Cook were I bought an
iPod I just got the pink touch it's
great Oh what hey Justine you're gonna
meet Tim cooking you're gonna tell them
that you bought a pink iPod okay all
right well I wish I could have a redo
but either way being here and getting to
meet the future generation of people who
are changing this world was
I look forward to being at WWDC and I
can't wait to see what this week holds
so if you guys are here be sure to say
hi and there are a lot of planes here oh
my gosh there's actually all the
scholarship people are all coming out
right now
Jana is here and my friend Tyler who is
also helping me film so if you guys want
to follow them as well I'll put those
links also the description and any of
the people that I talked to today I will
try to also put them there so you guys
can go check out their work now we're
gonna go to the Cupertino Apple Store my
phone was in my pocket it's disabled I
kept hitting the wrong buttons I don't
know what was in my pocket so I kept
hitting buttons he hasn't got the Apple
sword which one I don't we should go
there now we go there now should go
there now I'll go there now far away I
don't know
[Music]